[Music]
um
my one of my secrets is
i do not show up as my most
authentic selves because i'm afraid
of abandonment
[Music]
my secret is i don't believe people when
they say that they're proud of me
because i'm never proud of myself
okay so this is something i think about
fairly often i consider it one of
maybe the worst things i've ever done i
was
very young about 13 years old and
i was snorkeling in florida on a family
vacation and out on a coral reef
i found a gold ring and i was very
excited 13 year old boy
i snorkeled down picked it up and as i
came to shore i noticed
a woman looking in the water for
something
and when i went by her she asked if i
had found a wing
and i told her no
and walked away i ended up pawning it
for like 30 dollars
at that time and as i've gotten older
i've reflected on that moment many times
and realized i had the opportunity to
really make somebody's stay
and instead i chose a very selfish past
that
actually didn't benefit me much in
any way and this is something i've
pretty much held to myself
but i think about it almost weekly and
if i could go back and do one thing it
would be to give that woman
huge
[Music]
i live a very rigid life and so
to be a little rebellious i often refuse
to wear a seat belt
[Music]
uh so when i was 19 uh i stole my
twin brother's identity opened up a bank
account just to cash one of his old
paychecks
while he was off at college well that's
it
crazy story is i found fifteen hundred
dollars cash
all once randomly uh in an elementary
school bathroom what happened was some
lady ran in there
uh scared for her life we ended up
checking the bathroom to see anything in
there
it was fifteen hundred dollars and a
girl scout cookie container bag
counted it all cash and put it all into
the savings account
[Music]
so i'm a hair stylist and i secretly
hate when people open their eyes and
talk to me while i wash their hair
it's super creepy and
i have a bad angle and it's just a
really
intimate head massage between two
strangers and worst case there will be
open mouth and moaning and it's just not
fun i want it to be over but you want a
longer massage so you should close your
[Music]
eyes
one of my first boyfriends in high
school
had this little studio outside of his
house where he would go play video games
and we were hanging out there one
afternoon
and i was really really thirsty i think
i had like coughed or choked or
something i really needed something to
drink and there was this can of coke
on the table and i had told him like i
really need something to drink do you
have some water
and he said no and i grabbed the can of
coke and i took a swig of it and he said
but whatever you do
don't drink that can of coke because i
peed in it last night
and i was so embarrassed and scared that
he was gonna find out that i drank his
pee
so i immediately swallowed it and put it
down and i have never told anyone that
[Music]
when i was about six i shaved my
eyebrows off because a girl at my school
had
nice thin eyebrows and i wanted them too
but i ended up shaving off my whole
eyebrow
and i told my mom that my sister did it
when i was sleeping and my sister got
her ass beat my mom still thinks she did
that to this day
when i was 10 years old i found out my
dad was using sugar daddy websites
and it was very traumatizing he still
doesn't know i know to this day
my secret is i recently gotten divorced
and i've begun um today to meet
different guys and i'm having the time
of my life meeting and dating sometimes
two to three days a day
[Music]
um so i'm actually more in love with
my best friend who's a girl than my
boyfriend
of a year she's my soul mate my life
partner
my one true love we started
being best friends in college and it
escalated to
bigger and better things more so a
relationship and
a true spiritual soulful connection than
anyone else i've ever thought i've loved
and even though
i am in a heteronormative relationship
for the sake of
society and my parents and
wanting what i thought i want out of
life
i will never not love her more than
anything else
i told my whole family that i'm leaving
for
college in the fall but really i'm just
going to go to spain
and live there for i don't know how long
but
for some unforeseeable amount of time
[Music]
my secret is i'm 30 years old and i've
never had a boyfriend
and i've never been in love with anyone
besides unrequited love
[Music]
so in college when i was in junior year
i broke up with my ex-girlfriend and
by that time i weighed over 300 pounds
i almost killed myself if i don't lose
weight and
my grandpa who
changed the life of our whole family
passed away
and in the meanwhile i prepared
like for applying for master so all
these four major events
happened within two months i felt so
depressed and i i thought i cannot make
it
it's like i was totally broken down
one thing i still remember that changed
my mind is that
in the future after five years we really
care about it
and the answer is not really the only
thing that i care about
is that my grandpa who passed away and i
don't have a chance to
to meet him it is my biggest pity
ever in my life and for all the other
things
i can make it just give me some more
time and so
i deal with everything one by one and
then
now i'm like one
sixty pounds back to normal and i
applied
for the master successfully and i find a
good job i have a good boss who take
care of my
career path everything is fine so now i
have a positive end
the thing that is matters is that how
you treat your life
i don't want my i don't want to myself
my life
i just want to you know like make
everything come back to normal
and i know i can do it just believe
yourself
and no matter what happens trust your
parents trust your friends
and then you can make it and that's my
life thank you
okay okay bye now
hey everyone quick announcement i
decided to make a separate channel for
my podcast
it's going to be linked in the
description the new channel is called
hey stranger which as you know
is the name of my podcast if you enjoy
watching the video versions to my
podcast
make sure to subscribe on there that
would mean a lot i tried really hard not
to make a second channel because i just
didn't want a second channel but it
really made sense for the podcast to
have its own channel because
they're longer videos and i'm in them
and i'm usually not in my videos on here
so i finally decided to make the new
channel for it i really hope you guys
will consider subscribing on there again
it's linked in the description and yeah
so
for my main channel i'm back to my
regular schedule which is i'll be
uploading every thursday on here
just like we used to i'm back for my
break and for my podcast i'll be
uploading
every other tuesday so basically every
thursday on here
and every other tuesday i'll be posting
my podcast episodes on the new channel
that's linked in the description
and then of course you can still find
the audio versions of my podcast on all
the podcast platforms
and yeah that's pretty much it thank you
guys for everything
i love you all i'm happy to be back and
i'll see you next week